all right good morning uh
we have
just welcome to Joe Carr we have a
number of things we have to do and it
looks like we might have trouble
maintaining a quorum after 10 o'clock so
I'd appreciate everyone being efficient
all right rep director Morrow
thank you madam chair
um for the members and for the audience
we do not have our court stenographer
today uh it's her 50th wedding
anniversary so she is absent uh that
means the transcript of the meeting will
be thank you
will be done afterwards by her but it
will be done using the minutes that the
attorneys keep and the
video recording of this meeting that
means I would urge you to when you speak
make sure your microphone is on and make
sure it's close enough to you so that
the audio will be clear
also
um
it was raised by a couple of members at
the last meeting there is discrepancies
between your written agenda it's printed
out for you and the committee packet
that's online
the committee packet
is a little confusing because some final
proposals are listed in bold
that's only the ones that have more than
one uh
electronic item with them the others are
not in bulk so that makes it a little
confusing also the order that you see in
the meeting packet is not in the same
order as in the printed agenda that of
the printed agenda is correct we've
talked with it about this and it cannot
be corrected at least at this time if
they make try to make a structural
change to meeting packet then it throws
off everything else in the meeting
packet hopefully in the future that will
be corrected fortunately the
down the online version to get what we
want correct okay
so we only have regular members so far
except for Senator Gray
and he can sit in for Senator and this
for as long as he's here
and represent hack and Phillips
is expected and when she shows up she
can sit in for representative hatch
Madam chair yes we did hear from
representative groda this morning and
she will not be attending
that's why I didn't mention her
okay
we'll be here we'll be sick if she does
if you can sit in for Senator walk
Senator Whitley
okay any
so we've got the alternatives
of the minutes of the previous meeting
and he uh
do we have a motion move to approve
minutes as written and presented and the
additions Corrections or comments
represent okay are seeing none those in
favor
aye aye those opposed
okay that's the Menace is there anything
to be postponed
yes there is
yes Madam chair
um
there are four items
from the board of tax and land appeals
um there are items H through K final
proposals 22 195 through 198.
okay and there's also um
the item a oh no not a b on the regular
agenda that's the re-adoption of the
driver licensing rules the department
has requested a postponement to the next
month okay so that's five items to
postpone do we have a motion so moved
second
it moved by rep Senator Lange seconded
by representative Schmidt any discussion
seeing none
those in favor
aye aye opposed
all right
um
and there anything to be removed from
the consent agenda
all right seeing none do we have a
motion move to approved consent to
generous presented second okay moved by
Senator Lang the second by
representative Lynn those in favor
aye opposed
all right thank you
okay
and
the first item to take up is the fish
and game rules
and I'd like to comment that all the
people that seem to be interested in
fish the fish and game rules is that we
are not a policy committee we are not
going to hear any testimony on any of
the policy involved in setting the uh
rules and and uh schedules
so
uh
um yes this is um 2022 60. yes the
wildlife rules and licenses and permits
um the rule did receive a lot of public
tax testimonies so there's just a few
things
that I want to go over
um
one is that the there were some
questions about the public notice
um which notice for the hearings appears
in the rule making register once a week
this had three hearings
um some people said that there may have
been some religious discrimination
because one of them fell on Passover
um but it does not appear it appears
that the person that was complaining was
actually at one of the other three meet
of the meetings and submitted public
testimony
um so I don't believe that this Rises to
the level of religious discrimination
um
the many of the
comments also used a um
a percentage of 96 people 96 of the
population of New Hampshire and it's
used in different ways and I can't
confirm where that number came from so
just be aware of that or if you're
looking at the testimony
um
and then like you said the
so that the statute
um doesn't require
the commission or the department to
incorporate public comment it only
requires that they consider it
um and so this is a um
like just because somebody gives
testimony does not mean that they have
to put it in their rules
um they simply have to consider it so
this is a statutory issue if people want
this policy changed they need to go to
the legislature
um
I think that's everything
all right
Dr Morrow uh thank you I'd also add that
I noticed the majority of the public
comment uh said that the rules contrary
to public interest that is a basis for
committee objection however it appears
from the
emails Etc that were sent that
contrary to public interest in the
Public's mind appeared to be that it's a
bad idea uh because as the chair said
gel car is not a policy committee it is
not up to them to determine whether
something is a good idea or a bad idea
uh the committee has very limited basis
specific bases under their own rules as
to what is contrary to the public
interest
good morning
I'm Marty Mobley I'm the legal
coordinator for fish and game and with
me today is Dan Bergeron the chief of
our Wildlife Division and Andy Timmons
who is the head of our game program
by Statute fish and game is required to
set season dates and bag limits for
hunting and fishing these just deal with
the hunting aspect fishing rules are
something different and because we have
put into rule the dates in themselves
for two years every two years we need to
change the rules to update the date and
we also have a 10-year game management
plan and we we set the bag limits to
keep up with the game management plan
the only other changes in these rules is
that we are incorporating an online deer
registration as required and mandated by
Statute or legislation that was passed
last year
and we are adding a couple of
definitions reaping and Fanning which
are prohibited practices associated with
turkey hunting
um I think that's about that's about all
that we're doing there
happy to answer any questions all right
also I I did forget to mention there
were some
um Clarity comments on the rule but the
agency and I went through all of them
and they were all cleared up so
all right are there any questions from
the committee
director Morrow one for the housekeeping
measure uh if anybody that testifies
whether public or agency we'd ask that
you've please fill out a pink card so
that will enable our our transcription
of the hearing okay I
I fill out the yeah correct I've got one
here that's fine okay thank you
any other questions
oh comments
anyone have emotion make a motion to
approve was that I don't have any cars
from anyone in the public and as
we would like a statement from the
agency that you heard all the public
comments and have considered them yes
ma'am in fact we actually did adjust a
couple of things due to public comments
there was some uh there was a request to
expand the use of crossbows in Wildlife
Management unit L to be so we have done
that in this in this rulemaking so
anyone with an archery license in
hunting in WMU Wildlife Management unit
L can use their archery license and a
crossbow and um we were originally
intending to make it so that um you did
not have to register one turkey before
you took your second turkey in the fall
hunting season but there was some
concerns about that so we have re based
on public comment we removed that and
now it's gone back to that that you have
to register one turkey and then take the
second turkey all right thank you
move to approve
Megan okay moved by Senator Lang
seconded by representative Lynn any
discussion comments questions
okay seeing none
for those in favor
aye opposed
all right thank you very much thank you
all right uh Department of Safety
uh so the next item on the agenda
because uh 159 was postponed is going to
be 20 22
186. the agency did submit a conditional
approval for this particular proposal
that addressed uh
pretty much all the substantive comments
however it did convert some of the
comments into notes to the committee
just for informational purposes if the
committee would like me to go over them
I certainly will but I will go over at
least the first one which is found on
page one of the rule
the rule specifically says
that in the event of a dispute regarding
the interpretation of the federal
standard of application of any rule
Incorporated
by these rules
the federal interpretation of the rule
as it appears in the Federal Register or
the most recent version of the Federal
Motor Carrier safety administration
motor care regulation information system
shall be used now the statute that
addresses that is RSA 266 colon 72a
where the statute specifically allows
the agency to incorporate the Federal
Regulations into their rules and
additionally that if any amendments or
additions are made to that the federal
rules that have been adopted they are
automatically applied to the rules
without any further action on part of
the commissioner
with regard to I'd like to comment on
that section it's blatantly
unconstitutional
the using the interpretation and the
Federal Register is fine if it's you
know an explanation or whatever but
saying that the commissioner can adopt
the latest version without going through
rulemaking or having any approval is
against the Constitutional Clause that
says no law that has not been approved
by the people or their elected
representatives needs to be followed
so I hope you're uh
the agency is prepared to deal with that
and we I expect I'll be pursuing a
statutory fix
and just to address that comment as well
on my end I did look into that
particular concern and
under chapter 4 section three point
one two of the manual
um as the committee may know normally
yes you have to include a date when
incorporating a particular
uh
document or Internet content by
reference however there is an exception
if it's allowed by Statute and there are
actually two other statutes in RSA
541a21
for two other agencies that specifically
allow them to incorporate those
incorporate documents into their rules
without including a date one of them is
for DHHS which has to do with the
Medicaid Federal Medicaid regulations
and the other one is for the Department
of Transportation with regard to some of
their internal manuals so I just wanted
to also bring that to the committee's
attention
lovely
all right any questions comments
okay
unless you want me to go over the other
notes please I think we've sure so the
next note is on page two of the rule
text with regard to the definition of a
serious traffic violation this statute's
also very unique in that normally when
you adopt a definition that's defined in
statute you have to mirror the format
and language however this particular
statute not only lists what's considered
a serious traffic violation it also
allows the agency to adopt rules
that would also constitute a serious
traffic violation so that's why it's not
exact to the statute because the agency
is actually adopting additional
serious traffic violations in that role
the next one is on page four of the role
text it has to do with
some dates that are really no longer
relevant anyone who was born
prior to January 1st 2011 is is now over
21. so it's not a relevant paragraph
however after conversation with the
agency they want to keep it in because
that is still what is listed in the
statute
so even though it's irrelevant it really
has no
no further
uh yes so yes that at the top paragraph
C
um
and that actually should have been
highlighted to paragraph B
um so I apologize for that um regarding
RSA 21p 18.
um
so that was the top uh comment and then
the next note to jail on that particular
K page
um the statute specifically includes
only if being driven in interstate
commerce
um with regard to K
if that particular rule however after
talking with the agency the agency did
point out that in their introductory
language they do use inter Towing in
interstate commerce so that would
address uh that comment that I had as
well
good morning
Mike
there you go
good morning I'm attorney Dave hiltz I'm
here for the Department of Safety um uh
unless the committee has any other uh
specific uh Focus uh questions that they
have I just want to address the issue of
constitutionality
um so you know the the department
obviously can't dispute that the
legislature is the final you know
Arbiter decision maker on on policy
however it seems clear to the department
that the legislature has at least up
until this point expressed a clear
policy decision that it is acceptable
and legal to enact uh rulemaking
Authority that allows an agency to
incorporate by reference
third-party materials without specifying
a particular date or addition
and as attorney Ricard pointed out the
evidence of that is not only in the
statutes that we're talking about but
other statutes you know that pertain to
DHHS and Dot and those statutes live in
this committee's statutes they're in
541a they're in 541a 21 Roman 8 and 541a
21 Roman nine and also that in the
committee's rulemaking manual it's
specifically uh contemplates this
activity and again since it's brief I'll
be redundant the manual says that an
agency has to you know as long an agency
can incorporate outside material as long
as the agency identifies in the rule and
abides by a specific addition or date of
the document or a read-only dated copy
of otherwise undated internet content
and does not automatically adopt future
amendments unless Allowed by Statute
and
um yes thank you I can see why you're
you're saying you've got strong
statutory Authority I
happen to think the legislature has made
a mistake in that case but you're
relying on
authoritative sources for your actions
and I
okay
anyone else yes Senator okay so I guess
I I'm a little confused so I understand
we we will allow it uh incorporation by
reference without an explicit document
uh data document allow but only under
conditions that where the we've already
approved it for certain agencies it
sounds like we've done that for DOT and
DHHS we have not done it for the
Department you have done it for safety
it's the statute specifically says that
they can adopt the revisions
that's correct it's just not in 541a
it's within the Department's own
statutes to uh 66 colon 72a
any questions or comments
okay
nothing better is there a reason we
can't have a specific data document that
just can be updated a fishing game comes
every two years obviously to do their
rules is there any reason you can't have
a specifically a specifically data
document reference so this doesn't
happen
so my understanding thank you for your
question
um so I don't know that it's impossible
um I unfortunately don't have Personnel
from the state police here I was told
that everybody that was involved in uh
working on this rule set is in training
uh today
um so I I could seek a more specific
answer for you but you know what I can
tell you is you know these
um
these regulations that we're
incorporating by reference pertaining to
motor vehicle
Motor Carrier safety they're very
important they have to do with Public
Safety and if the if the federal
government amends changes
um you know interprets into published
Federal Register that the regulations
ought to be interpreted a certain way
um it's really the most efficient and
protective of the public to like have
those changes just be effective in our
rules immediately rather than to have to
go back every time the federal
government goes back to change any of
those regulations and I apologize I
can't speak more specifically without
Personnel from the division of State
Police
director Morrow
um I'm not sure in this instance or with
DOT but I know with Health and Human
Services the reason they have two
exception is well one of them for
example is a provider reimbursement
which is set by CMS and it changes
constantly so it simply could not be
done through the current rule making
process
yes I'm not sure that the
the motor of a carrier safety rules are
that uh
liquid Dynamic thank you that's the word
I was looking for
okay representative lamb thank you my
question was actually some are similar
to that do you know how frequently these
these um Federal Regulations are updated
so I
um I was able to speak with one person
um yesterday afternoon about this so I
wouldn't consider it to be like very
comprehensive but I to give you all the
information I had that person said that
there might be changes every three to
four years
um I that was one person that I talked
to I wouldn't consider it to be
comprehensive but passing along what I
was told yesterday that's what he said
okay thank you
representative Schmidt
thank you madam pure so it may well be
more efficient uh to do it this way and
indeed legal but I was the public and in
indeed how's the agency supposed to know
when these changes occur uh because the
public is not monitoring uh the federal
government's actions so how are they
going to be aware of the fact that the
regulations have changed
um so I have two points in response to
that and and I offer them as
respectfully as possible I don't mean
any offense but
um the the first is is that
these questions and answers are really
more appropriate for a a a legislative
committee session
um considering a bill to amend or repeal
this statute today the Department's
position is is there a statute on the
books that authorizes this activity and
there is and so we're asking that the
committee approved the rules as long as
the committee believes that the rules
are in line with the statute
um so you know whether the expression of
legislative intent and policy in the
statute is something that folks feel
differently about today than they did
before is really more appropriate in
session
thank you Senator Lang a question with
director Moreau this isn't due till June
could we he we gave him a question to
come back for is there any reason we
can't postpone this let him come back
with the why they can't incorporate by
reference but not on our end I don't
know if there would be an issue with the
agency thank you
thank you fine then I will suggest that
barring objections we will
move this to our next meeting
and ask the agency to come back with
some dates and more information
and I'm sorry which what what types of
dates do you want us to come back with
what date of these Federal rules are you
incorporating and when were they last
changed
is anyone else have any other thing
they'd like the agency to provide
all right
Madam chair we should have a vote on
that Madam chair move the postpone uh
until next month uh 186. second
okay move by Senator line seconded by
representative Schmidt
discussion those in favor
aye aye opposed
it's okay
we will wait your update
all right State Police toll list looks
like we've got this knowledgeable people
here okay so um the state police toll
list rules um the rules Implement a
statute that allows for the creation of
a rotating tow list for the State Police
to use in the event that a State Trooper
needs to have a vehicle towed the rules
are currently in effect as emergency
rules and they expire on July 30th of
this year I spoke with the Department
yesterday a couple of times and um we we
went through my comments and um he also
submitted a elite filed draft
conditional approval request which is
linked on the website and you do have so
um I went through that and it does
alleviate or does remove all of my
concerns
we can still go through them if you want
but we do need to have the committee to
First vote to accept the late filed item
before we can you know move on okay
I'll move that we accept the late file
motion is there a second second
and five
representative Lynn okay any discussion
those in favor
aye opposed
okay now we're on the late filed uh
conditional approval request oh yeah um
so um I had some questions because some
of the forms had indicated that they
were revised in January of 2023 but they
were brand new forms as it turns out
this is semantics the department
typically puts revised on all of their
forms even if it's the first time
they're doing a form so that kind of
threw me off you know why is it revised
if it's a brand new form but um so that
concern is is has been addressed some of
the forms two of them required the
submission of a social security number
and I wasn't sure where the authority
was for it but the agency is going to
remove that requirement on the
individual form and then on the business
form they're going to require the
federal tax ID number
so um I think that's okay so there's no
ban on collecting tax IDs from
businesses not that I know of um but the
department can probably talk about you
know why they're requiring it
um I'm not sure
um the other issues were around
um on page six of The Proposal it was um
around some of the language where the
where the rule was using the word May
and
um and it seemed to sort of you know it
had some general criteria for when the
colonel would consider deciding whether
or not to impose discipline for
violations of the statute but the use of
word may just kind of indicated that the
kernel may not take action and it wasn't
clear why or when that would take place
so um if you look there on the the draft
conditional approval on page six they've
changed some of that language and I
think it does a much better job of
laying out when that action would take
place and when it wouldn't
and then there was um on the next page
on page seven I had some concerns here
because the rule said that a tow
business May appeal any disciplinary
action that has taken place meaning it
took place in the past so my concern was
having that discipline take place before
you know a hearing could possibly you
know be problematic for due process but
um the statutes there that are cited in
106 actually state that the being on the
toe list is a privilege and not a right
and discipline can take place prior to a
public hearing but they do have the
ability to request a hearing you know
after the fact so um those were the only
issues that I had with the proposal
right Mr Hills thank you very much again
Dave hiltz for the Department of Safety
um
on the issue of the social security
number
um it was we clearly had the authority
to collect the social security number on
a form that wasn't being commented on it
was a roster of all the operator tow
truck operators that a business needed
to attach to their form the two forms
that there was a the question about one
was the individual application form so
basically everybody who was an operator
or an owner or manager or supervisor has
to fill out one of these individual
forms and we had the social security
number on that and arguably it is
appropriate if that form is filled out
by an operator but because if it could
get filled out by other people we just
decided to go without it on that form
because we're getting the social
security number authorized by statute on
the roster as to the business there was
no clear statutory authority to collect
the social security number and as The
Madam chair had said there's no specific
prohibition on collecting a federal tax
ID number for a business so to help I do
have other folks here Captain Hagerty
and Lieutenant Lop here to chime in if
um I don't fully answer the question but
my understanding is the federal tax ID
number would help to identify the
business
but otherwise we rectified the Social
Security Number issue on the authority
um on the May versus shall
um again the comment was with the May it
seemed like we had set up the rule in a
way that could contemplate that no
action may arise even though a violation
was found and so we did actually clarify
the rule as you see in front of you to
provide for that outcome that we
possibly could take no action again the
folks here from the division can step in
if there are other examples that they'd
like the committee to know about but one
would be if the division uh caught wind
of a a violation and when they looked
into it they found that it had already
been rectified
and if the nature of it was minor then
they very well may not take any action
so we decided to clarify the rule for
that and then again on on the appeal
um you know just the way that we had had
it
made it seem like there could have been
an ambiguity uh between the rule and
541a 30 Roman 3 for the uh
immediate suspension and so we just
clarified it to make sure that everybody
who read this rule knew that the way the
appeals were going to go were pursuant
to the toe rule statutes 106 b-31 Roman
14 and 106 b34 so we hope that the
committee believes that we've clarified
the rules sufficiently
um thank you are there any questions
from the committee comments
representative Lynn no
Senator Lang moved to approve
um additionally approved 66 as presented
and amended
second
okay moved by Senator lying second by
representative Lynn any discussion
comments questions I said one thing
manager yes I want to thank the agency I
had meetings with the Deputy
Commissioner on this issue going back
trying to get these rules in place and
you guys acted pretty quickly once I
asked so thank you very much you're
welcome okay
by Senator Lang second by representative
Lynn those in favor
aye those opposed
all right thank you very much thank you
all right the next one is at DHHS
um rule
2020 yeah 2022 160. it's on Telehealth
Services
the statute that requires um
rules for the
um
for this area Telehealth Services
um was actually effective in 2019 so gel
cart may have questions about how this
process has been done since then and
then the only substantive comment is
down on page four of the rule and it's
really it's just maybe this is just me
but the sentence just doesn't make any
sense to me
um and I think you guys have another one
to offer
good morning Allison radney
administrator for the administrative
rules unit for the Department of Health
and Human Services with respect to the
paragraph in D um in the unclear
um we would actually ask that we striped
that it is actually pretty redundant to
paragraph a in that section
um so we don't feel it's quite necessary
for it to be in there
um I why I have a question why are you
stating in the rule but people have to
follow the laws
I mean that
I would think that would be assumed
we do that in a lot of our rules we
always I think every single rule the
department has we always imply that they
have to comply with rules state law
federal regulations
okay thank you thank you
all right anything else
uh just to address the first part about
for the record Robert Berry uh general
counsel the division of Medicaid with
the Department of Health and Human
Services
um so when the law of that
um passed that directed the department
to adopt rules for Telehealth was late
2019 as we all remember 2020 uh kovid
became an issue
um so the executive order that the
governor had issued uh executive order
number eight uh dealt with Telehealth
services at that point when that expired
the department was relying pretty
heavily on the statutory scheme the
statute is pretty thorough as to
directing the department as to how to
administer Telehealth and it also has
references to federal regulations in
there as well so we felt that the uh the
statutory scheme and the Federal
Regulations were pretty sufficient at
that point in time
emergency orders which I've
okay any questions comments
move to approve with the edits
is there a second
okay moved by set Center to Lang second
by senator chandley
discussion those in favor
aye opposed
okay thank you thank you
uh the next item 2022 208
um the agency did submit a conditional
approval and additionally they submitted
an amended conditional approval and I
want to apologize in advance I just
noticed that's not posted online and I
have reached out to our administrative
staff back in the office to get that
posted as quickly as possible but the
only difference between the conditional
approval and the amended condition of
approval is that the substantive comment
I had on page three of the rule text of
the conditional approval the agency did
adjust that language to address that
comment so the only remaining comment I
had
is on um
page
I believe it's 20 22. thank you uh
the agency with regard to definition of
relative uses or references the federal
definition of relative as opposed to
using the state definition of related
and when I had a conversation with the
agency about this they stated it's
because the federal definition does not
include cousins Within
what is considered a relative well the
state statute of related refers or
incorporates first and second cousins
and because of that the federal agency
with whom they work was saying that they
would not qualify for certain funds and
I'll certainly let the agency address
that more directly
but that's the only remaining comment I
had
good morning I'm Nicole valenzola rules
coordinator excuse me for the Department
of Health and Human Services
um
good morning Ben Hoffman I'm the
business systems analyst with the Bureau
of Child Development and Head Start
collaboration
um so on March 2nd 2022 the department
received a preliminary notice of
non-compliance from the federal office
of child care so the majority of the
edits to this rule in front of you were
made to bring us into compliance with
the New Hampshire Child Care scholarship
program which does utilize Federal ccdf
which is child care and Development Fund
dollars so one of the areas that the
department was cited was our definition
of related when it comes to child care
providers
um
so in RSA as attorney Rickard mentioned
it means any of the following
Relationships by Blood marriage or
adoption parent grandparent brother
sister step parent grandparents
stepbrother stepsister uncle aunt niece
nephew first cousin or cousin the
federal office of child care in Federal
Regulations defines relative for the
purposes of child care providers as
Grandparents great grandparents siblings
if the siblings live in a separate
residence from the child aunts or uncles
um so the department uses a child care
licensing unit to conduct monitoring
visits of child care providers to ensure
that they are in compliance with our
health and safety rules relative
providers are exempt from monitoring
visits so essentially we were exempting
cousins and these other relationships as
well perhaps siblings if they did live
in the same unit as the um as the child
where they shouldn't have been Exempted
from the monitoring visits so that's
what we were cited for we're looking to
align our definition with Federal
Regulation so that we're not potentially
fined or lose any ccdf dollars
um
this uh the edits in front of you were
reviewed by the federal office of child
care they did indicate that these edits
would bring us into compliance
um and unfortunately I don't believe
that this is a simple
situation where we could propose a
legislative change to the stat
definition in statute because the
definition in statute is child daycare
licensing and we're talking about
license exempt providers here so I
believe that child care licensing unit
may use the same definition in statute
for other purposes
do I understand you correctly that the
only difference is that the
relative is does not get
visited for or inspected for compliance
that's correct
representative lamb um thank you madam
chair
um is it my understanding that if this
there's a sibling providing the care
that lives in the home then they're
inspected but if that sibling has a
separate house they're not or am I
getting that backwards that's correct
for federal regulations the Federal
Regulation requires that the sibling
live in a separate residence from the
child
that's great for our housing issues
thank you indeed
Rec Center is is there I know a lot of
our federal programs are state law and
what we've enacted is different than a
federal law and we apply for federal
waivers for a given program to because
of the conflict between state law have
we done that here
uh thank you for your question uh we
have been working directly with the feds
and they suggested that we not cite this
anymore so I mean we've been in
communication with them and they haven't
indicated that was even an option they
said that we need to stop exempting
cousins and and so forth from monitoring
visits
representative lamb um thank you madam
chair given our housing situation and
child care situation is it appropriate
to request a waiver so that these in
in-home siblings and cousins wouldn't be
subject to this uh these visits
I actually I think I need to make a
correction because relative
um sorry relative providers in the
child's home are actually exempt that's
my fault
so any relative provider who provides
care in the child's home is exempt from
a monitoring visit that's sorry about
that and a sibling of
would be would be if they're in a
whether they're in the same home or in
different
right so it's actually it seems to just
be the cousins primarily that is the
issue
all right
other questions
anything ever director Morrow
thank you I'd once again ask that
anybody that testifies please fill out a
pick card thank you
Madam chair I'm going to make a motion
to approve not reluctantly make the
motion to approve but also ask the
agency to try to
submit a waiver and see what the feds
say
and I apologize uh Senator is that
approving the amended conditional
approval yes thank you
actually I would if
issue is that you don't know who else is
using that statutory definition of
family or relatives you might instead
find out and if necessary correct
and amend the statute
if you think that's important whichever
you think would be more appropriate to
the situation yes we can go back to
child care licensing unit and discuss
with them uh you know they specifically
need cousins referenced or not
okay we have a motion to approve by
Senator Lang is there a second
second Senator chamley any comments
questions
okay seeing none those in favor
aye a pool opposed
all right your rule is approved and uh
we'll see what they can do
all right
all right the next one is the
um
office of licensed Allied health
professionals
um there's just a couple comments on
here one
RSA 328 F-15 gives the authority to ahp
but 310
a1d2h1 gives you authority to oplc
um so it's
it seems like these should be in the PLC
rules for oplc but I'm I'm just not sure
the statutes are conflicted statutes are
currently in flux yes and as far as I
know the entire Allied Health
Professional Organization is being
repealed in House Bill too
and
we hope that the oplc knows who's
setting the fees where okay
um so then the other issue is just um
paragraph B underneath the fee table
um this is because it says all fees
shall not be refundable but historically
um
there are certain fees that
are must be refundable so
um if you have an application fee
that the agency has done something with
the application
um and so you can keep that fee but if
you have a licensure like the
application is leading to a licensure
the the and the agency doesn't give the
person their license for whatever reason
denies the license then they can't keep
that the funding they have to give the
feedback
um and that's just been
kind of historically how we function
with the fees so
I wanted to bring that up and then
there's just a minor edit on the
appendix
okay thank you
um thank you madam chair members of the
committee Lindsay Courtney executive
director office of professional Ace
insurance certification
um I would ask that the committee
postpone consideration of
um this final proposal The Proposal
conflicts with oplc's filing which is
also on your agenda it's the offices
position that the board of Allied Health
directors does not have fee setting
Authority because of the conflicts that
have existed in statute we have seen
boards continue to file uh fees but I
think assuming that the oplc proposed
1002s moves forward that would obviate
the need for any filings by board so I
would request that the committee
postpone consideration and assuming 1002
is adopted we would go back to the board
and ask them to withdraw this proposal
so you're saying that this is redundant
to a proposal
um
we will consider in a bit and you want
to withdraw it
I don't have authority to withdraw it so
I would just ask that they can the
committee consider postponing this
consideration and we would go back to
the board that does have the authority
and ask them to withdraw it
yeah
okay we our deadline is not till late
June so yes is there a postpone thank
you okay second advice
Senator Schmidt narrowly first any any
discussion on postponing
I won't be showing up with the next time
okay
[Music]
um
those in favor
aye opposed
all right thank you we'll do that
and
Health and Human Services
all right this is uh 2022 230 it was
um
postponed from the last meeting
and
um there is a conditional approval
request the agency made changes based on
public testimony from the the last
meeting and you can see those changes on
the conditional approval request down on
pages
it's at the bottom like the 20
22 23
um
and I I
there was public testimony on this but
from what I'm seeing I think that it is
in compliance with the Federal
law
okay thank you
good morning Allison radmay I'm
administrator for the ministry of rules
unit for Department of Health and Human
Services
Melissa Nemeth I'm the attorney for the
Bureau of Developmental services within
the Department of Health and Human
Services and we do believe that the
changes that we have made in this
conditional approval requests have
addressed the most of the testimony that
was previously provided by the
stakeholders there is one area and I
believe they are here ready to speak um
and so I I'm not sure which order you
would like us to go in I I don't know if
you'd like to hear from them and then we
can respond I know the general nature of
some of their commentary and I'm ready
for them specifically okay so
um do you have any other comments that
you need us to know the only other thing
that I think she may bring this up as
well which was not in her other
testimony she did point out to us this
morning that on page 22
in 310.12
letter a number two the notice of the
rights to appeal gives an individual the
right to appeal within five business
days
however on page 20
in letter C five
then notice that they are excuse me
letter C six the the notice that they
repealing gives them three days to
vacate the resident so she has pointed
out that that is a conflict and that was
an oversight on our part so we would
certainly be willing to change make the
change on page 22 to allow that appeal
to be required to be filed within three
days so that those two time frames are
in alignment
we will
that could that be considered an
editorial con corre correction since
it's agreeing with the previous part
yes to be consistent with the other rule
okay thank you so we'll we'll take care
of that thank you and then we can be
ready to respond provide our feedback
after you hear from the public okay Ms
Rosenberg
foreign
thank you I think something is
circulating that I prepared for you all
my name is Karen Rosenberg I'm the
policy director at the disability rights
Center where this dates protection and
advocacy system for people with
disabilities and I'm here to ask that
you enter a preliminary objection to
these rules based on them being beyond
the agency's authority and this is on
behalf of the people of Developmental
Disabilities and brain injuries that are
our constituents who receive home and
community-based residential programs
here's why the federal regulations that
govern how Medicaid HCBS Home
community-based Services may be spent
require that individuals who benefit
from these Services who are in
residential programs receive the same
rights and protections that are
available to tenants under the state's
landlord tenant law and that applies
regardless of whether our landlord
tenant law would apply to the situation
so in that document that I sent you kind
of summarizing our the Salient points
here I've taken out and highlighted the
Federal Regulation that applies in this
instance
so while the department did work with us
to address some concerns what was not
addressed is the most important
distinction between what our state law
protections require and what these rules
would provide and what that is is due
process that is pre-deprivation under
our state landlord tenant law regardless
of the reason for eviction a tenant is
entitled to Due Process a hearing before
an impartial judge to determine whether
the landlord met their burden of proof
in the allegations that they made in the
notice to terminate the tenancy and that
occurs before the tenant is forced to
leave their property
that is that is the most important
aspect of of due process in this case we
don't deprive people of their property
interest that is so important their home
without providing the opportunity for
them to appear before a judge have
Discovery all of it and at that point if
the court rules against the tenant they
actually under our state law have a
right to appeal to the New Hampshire
Supreme Court and during this entire
time like I said regardless of the
reason for the eviction that tenant
remains housed the rules as proposed
carve out an exception for allegations
that are based on tenant behavior that
allegedly causes substantial property
damage or harm to someone else
now keep in mind that our our law says
we have we have untrained landlords they
did not sign up to work with tenants who
may damage their property or harm people
yet a tenant can remain in their home
even if they lose and they follow all
the procedures for around 90 days after
that initial eviction action while vague
contests that action under the rules as
proposed a resident would have to leave
in six days
they could appeal but what's the point
of that appeal if any Victory would be a
peric victory because they would be
unhoused at that time and we know how
hard it is to find housing in the state
and to come up with programs and another
difference here is that with the
programs that serve people with
developmental disabilities these are
trained these are providers that hold
themselves out as experts they are
trained experts who contract to provide
services to people with developmental
disabilities and brain injuries who may
actually engage in behaviors that are
challenging and they know that and
they're trained to deal with it they're
also paid a lot of money to do this so
budgets I mean we see budgets I mean a
hundred thousand dollar budget is not a
big budget for someone who is getting
for these kind of Residential Services
that's over eight thousand dollars a
month at that level
our private landlords are not
are not receiving that kind of
remuneration and yet they actually have
to comply with fundamental principles of
due process so for those reasons I think
that these rules do not provide
comparable protections as our landlord
tenant law does and that an objection
should be entered and I'm happy to
answer any questions
thank you are there questions
so I'm still trying to I apologize thank
you I'm still trying to follow the
process here right and understand so
there is that there is an under a 12 a
number three
right so if someone files an appeal they
get to remain in their residence or in
the notice requirement we tell them that
they file an appeal they get to stay in
their residence right is that correct so
yeah and actually that's what that's
what that chart shows you is so under
12a there's an ex there's an exclusion
so you get they get one three-day notice
I think if you follow the chart that I
provided that refers to the role it may
be more helpful
so you'll see on the right hand side of
that chart it tells you the initial
notice that you get is a three-day note
a 72-hour notice
after that then you get the set a second
notice three days to vacate
you actually if if the reason for the
termination of The Residency agreement
under these rules is alleged behavior of
the tenant that is property damage or
physical harm then
you leave you can file an appeal
but you are out
you can stay for those three days but
after those three days you're done
if you if the reason for eviction is
something other than those
two reasons then you can stay longer
while you fight your appeal
so if I understand you correctly the
only people who are affected by this
rule change
as opposed to normal housing landlord
tenant laws are the people that are
causing uh bodily harm and property
damage well the thing is we don't know
if they're actually causing it like in
our landlord tenant law there's an
allegation
and we don't allow our landlords to
determine if their allegations are true
we require a judge to determine if the
landlord's allegations are true
so similarly
if there's an allegation that there's
property damage or harm we don't we
shouldn't allow the trained provider
agency to be both the prosecutor and
judge
thank you
any other comments questions
okay
thank you very much for your testimony
thank you
and uh we'll hear it from the agency
good morning again for the record my
name is Melissa Nemeth an attorney with
the Bureau of Developmental services at
Health and Human Services
um and and the department
feels that this rule does meet the
requirements of the Federal Regulation
in that the regulation says that the
rights of the individual if the landlord
tenant laws do not apply which is the
case in New Hampshire for this
population that in these settings there
need to be protections and again that
address eviction processes and appeals
comparable to those provided under the
landlord tenant law and so you
comparable does not mean 100 equal and
the department has tried to make this as
equal as possible as in alignment with
the landlord tenant law as possible with
the exception of this one
um cohort that Ms Rosenberg has
testified to but unlike in landlord
tenant law I'm looking now at page 20 of
our conditional approval request in
letter c
number four excuse me number four is
where they would get the notice to that
there's an intention to terminate their
residency agreement
um within 72 hours based on their
behavior number five and this is a
difference that something that does not
exist in the landlord tenant law but we
have added for this population is that
in that case within 24 hours that
individuals the the resident their
service coordinator or their team has to
convene a team meeting in 24 hours to
determine and take the appropriate
course of action to ensure that they're
going to have access to a safe
alternative residence so the the
intention here is that while they may
not be staying in the same place that
they were they're not going to be
unhoused or rendered homeless and in the
typical landlord tenant law that kind of
a resource is not available to the
tenant another concern of the department
is that not only you know we have these
the Federal Regulations this is One
Federal Regulation that we need to
comply with
Additionally the we have the overall
responsibility as a department to ensure
that the rights of all of the
individuals that are supported are being
protected so in a case of of this nature
it could be someone lives in a community
residence with you know there could be
six individuals living there and if
their behavior is causing bodily harm to
other individuals in that residence
allowing them to stay there throughout
an entire appeals process could put the
other residents at risk and also put the
department and their providers at risk
of not protecting the rights of those
other individuals that live in the home
so there's a balance that has to be
stricken here too with the department so
we we do feel like the provisions we
have provided are in compliance with the
federal law
um
yes thank you so again walking through
this so there's a couple different so in
a normal process they get a 90-day
notice and they get they get notified of
their rights and there's a meeting that
occurs within 10 days upon notice of
those rights of that they're being the
proposed eviction is going to happen in
90 days however in the case of a
resident where we have harm a potential
harm
um they're they're they don't get that
90-day illness they only get a 72-hour
notice yes and in that 72-hour notice in
addition to getting that notice
um you also for that for that CL for
those uh residents they get
um a meeting within 24 hours with their
service coordinator or designee
to convene a team meeting to see what to
do about this that's correct and the and
the team needs to like take those
appropriate actions to make sure they
have that access to the safe alternative
residence in the 90 days that's that
meeting is to like talk about what is
the transition plan going to be but the
requirement here is if that notice
you've been notified you know there's an
intent to have you leave in 72 hours
we've got to get something done quickly
and not only talk about a future
transition but what are we going to do
right now to ensure someone has a safe
alternative follow-up so then if that's
if that person in that 72-hour period or
their designee or service coordinator
files an appeal what happens so
um there's one other step so they get
that 72-hour notice is their first
notice if they don't leave within that
72 hours they get a additional notice
that is that they need to vacate within
three days and that's in number six so
that provision applies that that second
notice that actually says now it's now
you have to vacate that applies whether
your original notice was 90 days or 72
hours and it's that second three day
notice that can be appealed and then the
appeal provisions
for if anyone getting the 90-day notice
that says you would stay in your
residence but if you
the allegation is your behavior you've
gotten that notice because your behavior
is dangerous then you don't have the
right to remain in your residence during
the pendency of the appeal
but the alternative is that your team
has met and you at least you have a safe
alternative residence to go to within
that time frame
I would certainly feel a lot better
about this rule if it was explicit that
eviction cannot be you they can't be
evicted because they're waiting for a
safe place or if their team can't find a
safe place I mean you I agree you need
to protect the other residents
but
um
representative Hawkins Phillips so I'm
sorry I have been out of practice now
for about a year and a half and I am
struggling to remember
there is an emergency
[Music]
um
format to work outside of 540A to
expedite a hearing before a judge if
there is harm being caused on the
property I'm struggling to remember the
RSA number
um for
um
for this purpose but um I think there is
a way a tenant or a landlord can apply
for a temporary injunction
an expedite a quick 10-day hearing
notice if there's some sort of
Harmony as to you shaking your hand head
um you don't think it applies
um my my recollection is that there is
an alternative
um Avenue to expedite a hearing before a
judge within a short shorter time period
my question
I mean
let me just say blankly that I'm feeling
a little uncomfortable about moving
forward with this role because I it
seems like there is a major gap between
what the department is saying
is providing accurate and full um
compliance with regulations and then
also hearing from people who regularly
are aware of tenants rights possibly
being
um
being violated you know their due
process being violated so
um with that thought I I just think
um
you know if there is this alternative
hearing process to expedite a hearing
before a judge my question would be
you know if that is given to regular 540
tenants why would that not also be
extended to people who fall under this
subcategory
um
as a general statement I don't believe
that this group subgroup of folks who
are being affected by this rule should
have fewer due process rights than a
regular tenant under who might fall
under 540 that feels
um like the opposite of what the intent
of the law
would be in my opinion
so
thank you I'm not sure where I'm going
with that but I just I think that that's
it seems to me that we're quite far away
from being happy with with this rule is
meant to do
so I
thank you so the chairman had to leave
so I'll take over so I guess the
the question comes you have 72 hours and
72 hours these people that are at that
put other people at risk or at least
have been accused of putting other
people at risk and at the end of those
272-hour periods what happens to them so
they would have a they would need to
move from that residence and their team
would have helped them locate a safe
alternative place to go
um to representative Maguire chairman
McGuire's Point
um we have language in there that they
determine and take the appropriate
course of action and ensure that the
residents has access to an alternative
safe residence that's where we've tried
to make it clear I think she felt that
it wasn't as explicit as maybe it could
be that someone that this is what is
required and they would this is where
they would need to go and I you know
sometimes as we as we all know there are
um housing you know it's difficult to
locate housing here sometimes it might
be something on a temporary emergency
basis um there I know there have been
instances where
this isn't ideal but someone might go to
a hotel room they would have staff with
them the appropriate staff with them but
while something is located for them um
so they're they would not be you know
rendered homeless or put out on the
street they would their something would
be found for them even if it's uh it
would be safe and appropriate although
maybe less than their ideal ultimately
where they would be going but there
would some be something found for them
in that interim time frame and if they
don't find anything because given the
housing situation right now what happens
well I like I said I think this would be
you know it would it might be an
emergency it might be a respite with
someone with a family
um or in a hotel I
the provider Network in New Hampshire
you know independent of the housing
bridge that we have for you know all
citizens
there are certain providers that provide
these services for these individuals so
locating them you know there can be it
might take time to have someone move out
it's kind of a domino effect sometimes
one person has to move out for another
person to move in
um so I think that there would be that
these protections are there and in fact
these these things are there this
happens now independent of whether we
we're adopting this rule or not would
um in these situations now work is done
to ensure and it can take a variety of
um
it can go in a bunch of different
scenarios but there is work done by all
the providers to make sure that people
are getting the supports that they need
so on the department doesn't have
concerns that there would be nothing
found for someone and that they would be
rendered homeless um but that the the
team that what we have in here has
enough requirements for their team to
find something for them
further discussion uh representative
Lynn yeah I guess I'm just wondering the
I mean it seems to me that that the
rules in us and do not take account of
other avenues I mean I I assume that if
in under four for example if a resident
was posing serious threat of bodily harm
or serious property damage
if I think we have to be careful because
if we make the
if we make the the restrictions on the
landlord so to speak or the the manager
of the of the thing too restrictive it
would seemed to me in other words if if
I'm the if I'm the manager of this
property and and there's a resident
who's you know I can making ongoing
threats to other residents or me or the
whoever and I don't have any ability to
to remove the person in some reasonable
manner my alternative is to go to the is
to go to the go to the courts or file a
com ask for you know the police to come
and arrest the person and get them
involved in the criminal justice system
which may not be
uh may not be the best thing but but
presumably if they did do that the court
the court might say in those
circumstances you know I'm going to
issue a bail order that says you can't
you can't associate with the place where
you were living you have to go live
somewhere else
um which might not be what what uh what
would be the most of most uh most
appropriate thing that that you know
someone in this rosenberg's position
would think is a good idea
in in the department would you know that
would not be something we want to happen
but it can and does happen in in today's
world in extreme circumstances I uh you
know providers aren't jumping to that
but sometimes the situation is does call
for that
um and and the other I think another
risk here too and something again when I
was talking before about balancing we do
have a limited provider Network and and
to your point representative and if the
providers don't feel like there is
recourse that they can take that might
be reluctant to accept individuals and
there could be a risk of you know I I
don't know the numbers that I can tell
you but there could be a risk that
providers would decide that if these are
the parameters then that might be not be
a business noun that they would like to
go into because they don't want to be
put in that situation where they have
someone acting in that manner and they
don't have any recourse okay
representative
thank you Mr chairman so I I think the
the word has not been spoken recently
but it was spoken by Miss Rosenberg uh
word is allegation uh so I I think
that's the concern it's a balancing act
we're all obviously seeing that
um that if you have an allegation of of
threat or harm or or uh or violation uh
of someone else's rights including the
landlords uh then then the the potential
Hammer is
they get yanked out after a couple of
days on the basis of an allegation and I
think that underlying question is going
to be
what uh what modality is there in order
to ascertain what the reality is whether
the allegation is is based in reality in
other words it is really happening that
person is being uh the landlord or the
other tenants are being threatened or
harmed or damage is being done and
that's a real situation then clearly all
the other parties have a right to have
that that harm stopped
and have that person removed but the
question is is the allegation
substantiated or not and I think that's
the point that Miss Rosenberg was was
underlying uh making as her underlying
argument so I mean it's obviously a very
difficult situation with all the other
parameters are involved
so I I'm troubled by the the situation
if there's no intervening authority to
to examine the reality the situation to
establish that
otherwise a person is the tenant is
potentially deprived and becoming
unhoused
all right represent Leon for a question
thank you Mr chairman
um are these are these residential
housings for this community considered
Health Care Facilities under our
statutes they are they can be certified
or licensed under uh it depends on the
amount of residence that they have in
them so if it's three or fewer they
would be certified by the health
facilities licensing of Health and Human
Services and if there are four or more
they would additionally be licensed
thank you so this actually brings up
another sorry if I can have a follow-up
this brings up another conflict we have
um set up the library 58 which is
talking about the warrantless arrest in
healthcare facilities that may end up
being the what what could be used if
somebody is causing potential bodily
harm and there's allegations of it I
don't know with the deadline of May 23rd
and I know that I also need to go
somewhere so we have Quorum issues how
technically we we handle this because
this this doesn't seem like it's quite
ready but I know we're also bumping up
on a deadline so I'm not sure what the
right procedure is
Dr Moreau if you wanna
uh regarding the rule the committee
could postpone
um
I'm trying to see
they would need a waiver would need a
waiver by the committee uh from the
committee would need a waiver from the
director in order to postpone so before
postponing I I want we in the beginning
of this whole hearing we started with an
agreement on a change of some a date
timeline where was that in the rule
again I apologize
that was on page 22.
it's in
310.12 letter a number two
it was changing five business days to
three days
you know I wonder if you could tell I
mean it sounds like this and it sounds
like appropriately maybe this might we
may end up postponing this but I'm
wondering
um when you come back it would be
helpful I think to all of us to know
what our other states do what kind of
regulations have they adopted for these
situations in other words do they have
do they have the sort of shortened time
frame
from a regular landlord tenant situation
that that you're proposing here and if
you know if if you came back to us and
said you know this 23 states do
something similar to this that's going
to be pretty persuasive to me on the
other hand if there's if there's uh if
everybody if all the other states don't
do something like this then that would
also be informative
put that piece of information you'll be
able to get if if we were way at Grant a
waiver and postponents till next month
is that something you can bring
um to us we can certainly look into that
I don't know how readily available that
information is um but it's something
that the department could look into
sure I mean I just have some suggestion
I mean I assume you might call HHS you
know the feds and just say look can you
tell us what what do all the other
states do and can you give us some
examples and that they'll presumably
would be able to do that
thank you so our our
position we're in and Dr tomorrow
correct me if I'm wrong we can um
there's a
this is a conditional approval a
conditional approval request has been
submitted so we can conditionally
approve I I'm I'll be honest I'm feeling
a little better and I know that no one's
going homeless in this situation and
while it's being conditionally approved
and going on that we're not going to be
putting people out on the streets with
this they may have to go to a different
place with this abbreviated timeline
only as it relates to people who are
putting other people at serious risk of
or property damage so I'm feeling better
about that piece but I would
um so the questions do we conditionally
approve this and let them know that it's
not the final rule that they'll be
coming back but it gives them a set of
rules to work on when do these expire or
have they expired uh so the rules we
were working on these they weren't
expiring we were making these changes
because we had to pour the federal
government to come into compliance with
the Federal Regulations so I don't have
that in front of me I don't know if I
don't think they're nearing any
expiration date
so Dr tomorrow if we do a conditional
approval what does that mean does that
mean they have to come back with a final
proposal
no it doesn't uh they have the final
proposal they have the conditional
approval request if the committee
approves the conditional approval
request they have to file a conditional
approval response the text of that has
to be identical to their request it
simply goes to our office we confirm
that the two documents the conditional
approval request and the response are
identical and in that case they can go
ahead and adopt the rule and then it
becomes a final approval in essence yes
and with an emotion to approve for
conditionally improve the committee can
also make recommendations or petitions
or other requests of the agents
these rules were last effective in 2015
so they're not expired yet
representative so I just wanted to
comment that I think what we're talking
about is the possessory interest of the
of the unit and we're talking about
people who are not regularly functioning
members of society but people who have
brain injuries and you know are having
real challenges in life so you know I'm
just thinking through my normal
experiences of a landlord tenant law
when there are instances of emergency
needs or substantial property damage or
even harm being done to folks in their
uni you know adjacent units a six day
removal is a very quick timeline
um even in normal circumstances I think
that you know without a hearing before
judge it's not permissible so
um I am very concerned about you know
asking people who are with brain
injuries to be removed from their home
within six days and temporarily put
somewhere else and I think that's what
we're really talking about and we're you
know you have to think through that who
is going to assist these folks moving
all of their personal property out of
these spaces in this you know presumably
time of Crisis for these folks so
um you know when we're talking about you
know this alternative service that might
be able to help someone on day seven you
know out of this possessory interest of
their unit
you know that's a pretty big
pretty big deal this especially for
those folks you know who may not be of
you know competency at the moment to
really assess and grasp what's going on
so they're going to be relying on other
folks at the state or or where or these
networks of you know support to help
them through that crisis
so I think we really do need to pause if
there is no emergency to push this role
right now I think we really need to
assess the situation have a better grasp
of what it is
um that process is going to look like so
I I I'm not comfortable moving forward
with the conditional approval at this
time so I just remember we're not a
policy committee right so generally
that's not what we we step into we can
give our recommendations We additionally
approve them said we want you to do this
there's no obligation for them to do
this but we're not a policy committee so
doctor that's basically what I was going
to say that the issue with the committee
is does the department have the
authority to do this is it consistent
with legislative intent
so we've already granted we've granted
in law waivers for them the normal
landlord tenant laws for this so it's
definitely within their right to make
changes and to make these conditions so
um I
I just make a statement we can we can
agree to wave and move on but uh you
know wave that wave the timelines make
them come back next month and see if
they're willing to change the policy but
again I don't think there's any
obligation for them to change the policy
because what not a policy committee we
don't set policy here we just decide
whether or not it's within the law and
within the intent of Law and
constitutional and make a recommendation
of Grant
we do have the authority if if we
if we do what what has been referred to
as a waiver we can we can get ourselves
we can get more time and ask them to
give us to to give us some additional
information
yes the committee can postpone this to a
future meeting they will have to request
from the director of legislative
Services a waiver of the committee's own
45-day deadline to act like I'm I guess
I would be inclined to do that to do the
waiver thing just because I I think I
mean I I really would like to know I I'm
my inclination is that I I share many of
the things you've already said but I
would like to know what are others you
know I'm not saying I expect some of you
to come back and tell us you know here's
a list of all the 50 states and here's
what they've done but if you could come
back and give us at least some
information that says you know here are
what other states have generally done
and if it's generally consistent with
this that I think that's that's going to
be good enough for me
um but I but I do think we need to know
something about that so representative
is that a motion Grant the waiver and
postponed next month and request the
agency bring in data regarding what
other states are doing yes that's what
it is so that's the motion that's the
motion okay
and it's been seconded by representative
Schmidt
so the motion on the table is to Grant a
waiver on timelines and to uh postponed
this until next month and have the
agency bring in data about what's going
on in other states right
Dr tomorrow we're okay with that motion
yes thank you
any further discussion hearing none all
those in favor say aye aye all opposed
name yeah I just have it we'll see you
next month ladies
thank you
chair
I just want to mention one
one that uh just for the record earlier
uh on I believe it was the Telehealth
Services vote Senator gray seconded the
motion I believe Senator uh
representative McGuire may have
I second in the motion which I totally
did
in in spirit agree with but just for the
record it probably his best that it
reflected it was Senator Gray thank you
so we'll move on to the next one I
greatly apologize but I have another
meeting scheduled and I'm not sure if
we'll have a quorum at that point
uh uh let me just take a look at what we
have here
I don't know
share something back no I don't believe
so she's done yeah I believe so I don't
think she's coming back so Mr chairman
yes if the committee uh needed to
postpone because of the lack of Quorum
uh the only other item that would
require a waiver uh to avoid being
automatically approved is the last item
from the Department of administrative
Services final proposal 2022-164.
um
that would need a waiver so can you
staple one more quick hearing and then
we'll
Grant we'll do this one and then we'll
postpone everything else yes all right
so if we jump to
um the objection response for Department
administrative services and do that one
and I do promise this is gonna be very
very quick because essentially what is
um
happening at this point I know
preliminary objection responses are
fairly rare
um
and normally the only course is to
either approve
um
enter our final objection or uh
to
accept the response as written as
addressing the issues however in this
case there were still remaining issues
with the response I've had conversations
with the agency they want to fix these
issues so there is one mechanism to do
that and that is for a revised objection
to be issued by the committee to allow
the agency to do a revised objection
response in order to do that the agency
has to request the revised objection and
then it would have the same timelines as
an objection response the agency would
had 45 days to
submit it to our office and then the
committee would have 50 days to act on
it
good morning to the committee I'm Janice
Emery
I'm the health benefit plan policy and
compliance administrator at Das
good morning my name is Catherine key
and I am the Deputy Commissioner at Das
thank you for hearing us today
as attorney Ricard mentioned we are
requesting the opportunity to prepare
and submit a revised objection response
we've been working closely with attorney
Ricard and we
want to thoroughly address all the
comments that we've received from her
office so we would appreciate the
opportunity to continue working on these
rules so that we can provide
um as clear and as functional roles as
possible thank you for considering our
request
so our actions here are to accept their
revised objection request and allow them
to present the information to the to the
to enter a revised objection to the
proposal do we need to take a motion on
that so moved so the motion is to accept
is there a motion to accept the revised
objection response request
second Leon and second of my
representative Lynn any further
discussion seeing done all those in
favor say aye aye opposed name eyes have
it and ladies will expect your paperwork
Mr chairman yes I was mistaken about uh
what else would uh be automatically
approved if it doesn't have a waiver
items m n and o on the regular agenda
will uh committee's deadline will be met
before the committee's next meeting so
if in one motion you wanted to uh
request a waiver from the director of
legislative services for those three
items he may do so so what I'm looking
for is a motion that will do two things
will uh Grant request a waiver for all
timelines on the remaining items on the
docket so they can be postponed until
next month so we'll spend move to their
second second
been moved by representative Smith
second my representative Leon all those
in favor say aye aye all opposed name
eyes have it there's no other business
come before the uh committee the
continued meeting that's canceled
or do you want to take this no I didn't
we move one item to the continued
meeting I I was thinking
I believe it was to the next regular
meeting the nope we can cancel the next
continue meeting
thank you
all right we're adjourned
foreign